we're delighted that we're announcing a
trial for 5g we're launching at the o2
arena you know the iconic venue
why not has our name on it and we are
super excited about the opportunity that
5g presents so for our customers that
come in the lounge will have a 5g like
experience so you can really get to
experience the the look the feel and the
benefits that will come through for 5g
but it's not just about 5g we've been
investing an awful lot of money over the
last couple of years and we were the
only network to sign up to 98 percent
indoor coverage and I believe we
achieved that were waiting for a
verification from the regulator and our
customers they're feeling the difference
that's not to say that there's more to
do because of course there is but we
were pleased they voted us the best
network coverage provider last year so
that's encouraging work that we need to
do more
I mean we haven't even had the 5g
spectrum auction yet I mean is it
realistic to start talking about when
that's going to be April May time you're
right we haven't had the auction it's
been somewhat delayed there were a
number of organisations litigating the
courts have dismissed those claims and
I'm pleased to say that we can now have
that auction and press ahead so there
are additional airwaves that the UK can
use and consumers can benefit from so
I'm hopeful that we only now have to
wait a matter of weeks for the regulator
to announce the approved bidders and
this auction can get started now
famously of course the industry lost a
packet on 3G I mean paid the government
twenty two and a half billion pounds
Gordon Brown was Chancellor at the time
there's no danger of that happening
again that sort of sum of money being
blown on the 5g auctions honour I I
would I would doubt that in but it's
going to be a very competitive auction
you know customers have an insatiable
appetite for mobile connectivity our
network has experienced an uplift in
demand of 60 percent just last year so
I'm sure every operator will be wanting
to attend that auction and can compete
fiercely for the additional airwaves
that will enable them to grow and then
evolved into 5g
now bt has been getting official kicking
from everyone for not investing enough
in fibre to the premises is 5g gonna
obviate the need for that fiber
investment now actually even in today's
network in ninety percent of our sites
are connected by fiber and the UK does
need fiber and today we have penetration
to properties of just about three
percent so I'm pleased the BT of
recently announced they're going to
extend fiber they announced three
million homes by 2020 we're working as
an industry to see if we can increase
that number we need to increase that
number
so fiber penetrations needed not just
for the fixed line business but also for
mobile if we're really going to get the
full benefits that phi g has to offer
and very very briefly your own by
telephone of course bainer they still
committed to the UK although very much
committed to the you came you know i
mentioned in the last couple of years
they've invested historic amounts we
have the auction upon us and and we'll
want to get exactly what our customers
need to strengthen experience